indes handelsakademie kurz ehec in
wiener neustadt am dienstag besucht
verteidigungsministerin klaudia tanner
die bildungseinrichtung wir sind
wirklich eine ausnahme schule in ganz
österreich und vielleicht sogar ein
ganzen deutschsprachigen bereich wir
sind eine handelsakademie das ist der
kernbereich an verschiedenen stationen
verschafft sich die
verteidigungsministerin einen überblick
über die umfassende ausbildung an der bh
quo ein weiterer schwerpunkt im
schulautonomen bereich liegt nämlich
dass in diesem schulautonomen bereich
führung und sicherheit rezitiert
vermittelt wird und dann noch die
zusätzliche china den außerschulischen
erweiterungs bereich in dem die
schülerinnen und schüler und kadetten
genannt dass die dann von in den
sicherheitsrelevanten die militärischen
bereich einige vorkenntnisse lange
nachdem die bewag schon einmal vor einer
möglichen schließung gestanden ist
findet verteidigungsministerin klaudia
tanner klare worte zurzeit besuchen 87
schülerinnen und schüler in zwei
jahrgängen die bewag die für ihre
vielfältigen möglichkeiten sport zu
betreiben bekannt ist
schülerinnen und schüler zu haben die in
guten konditionellen zustand sind die
auch weil es ja einen zusammenhang
zwischen der psychischen und physischen
leistungsfähigkeit gibt dass es dann
eben dort die eignungen da sind wir
haben herausforderungen im psychischen
bereich besser bestehen zu können